hmm big question I'll take a deep breath
first of all since I'm someone with a
lot of great faith I would try and I
think the key issues I have to start
with how we bring up our kids starting
with them believing in themselves and
believing that the world is a good place
that obviously requires education to be
in the forefront I mean had the
privilege to travel frog through many
parts of the globe I've discovered that
the things that unite us as human beings
are a lot more important than the things
that divide us but we're not exposed so
we come to many issues with stereotypes
and I think kids are great because you
know I'm an African and when you look at
kids kids up to in the very early ages
they generally do not know black or
white gender anything and that's a good
starting point because once you believe
in that good in your neighbor that's the
first step and dialogue so I would then
take it the next step on this is not my
unique idea and one of the discussions
we had yesterday idea someone made a
suggestion for these web meetings and
other big forum meetings we've adopted
western-style meetings offer we meet and
we get straight to the point however if
we could implement a policy of spending
the first half a day just to get to know
each other nothing at all with the
business we do want to
discuss and engage with the process of
getting as to know each other means that
we build more confidence with each other
it makes us more accountable to each
other so really again that would boil
down to communication so in the higher
education space I would say we should
learn a lot more languages because that
health education and I think once we do
all of that have a lot more trust in our
fellow human beings and trust in God
definitely the world would be much
better and all the other benefits would
be easier because we are blessed with
lots of resources lost more resources
than people that